BUCKS AND THE SAINTS.
IT HAS BEEN A FUN WATCH
CERTAINLY WITH TEDDY BRIDGE
WATER AS QUARTERBACK AND THIS
COACH MAKING THE CALLS WITH JOE
BRADY AND EVERYBODY ELSE THERE
BEHIND HIS VISOR.
JOINING US THE HEAD COACH OF
THE THREE AND TWO CAROLINES
MATT RULE HOW?
>> GOOD.
HOW ARE YOU.
>> BETTER FOR TALKING TO PU AN
WHAT AN INTEREST THREE WEEK
STRETCH IT HAS BEEN FOR YOU.
WHAT DID YOU SAY TO YOUR TEAM,
0-2 WITH KRISTEN MCCAFFREY ON
THE SHELF.
WHAT WAS THE SCENE LIKE FOR
THAT?
>> WE WENT OUT AND PLAYED TAMPA
BAY AND WE HAD FOUR TURNOVERS
AND STILL A CHANCE TO WIN AND
DOWN 7 IN THE 4th QUARTER AND
THE MESSAGE WAS LET'S STOP
TALKING ABOUT HAYWARD AND IF WE
CAN DO THIS AND THAT WE CAN DO
IT.
SO I THOUGHT THAT WAS A WEEK
THAT OUR TEAM, EVERYBODY TOOK
MORE ONUS ON THEIR OWN
SHOULDERS AND WENT OUT TO THE
CHARGERS AND PLAYED WITHOUT
CHRISTEN.
BUT A LOT OF THE GUYS STEPPED
UP AND THEY HAVE DONE THAT IN
THE LAST THREE WEEKS AND FUN TO
BE A PART OF IT.
>> IN TERMS OF STEPPING UP, IS
THIS WHAT YOU ENVISIONED FROM
TEDDY BRIDGE WATER WHEN YOU
WENT IN THAT DIRECTION PARTING
WAY WITH CAM SINCE YOU HAVE
SEEN HIM PERFORM IN NEW ENGLAND
THE WAY HE HAS PRIOR TO HIS
COVID POSITIVE DIAGNOSIS.
IS THIS WHAT YOU ENVISIONED
TOWARDS TEDDY BRIDGE WATER,
COACH?
>> YES.
WE HAD A TREMENDOUS FEELING
THAT LIKE HE WOULD BE A GREAT
FIT FOR THIS SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW.
WE ASKED THE QUARTERBACK TO
OBVIOUSLY TO BE ACCURATE AND TO
GET THE BALL OUT QUICKLY.
BUT TO GET THROUGH PROGRESSION
AND TO MAKE ALL OF THE CHECKS.
TO GET US IN THE RIGHT PLAY AND
WE HAD SEEN TEDDY DO THAT IN
THE FIVE GAME STRETCH IN THE
LAST YEAR AND A SIMILAR SYSTEM
AND FELT IF HE GETS A CHANCE
WITH US AND GIVEN THE RANGE HE
CAN TAKE THIS TO ANOTHER LEVEL
AND I THINK HE CAN COMPLETE 73%
OF THE PASSES AND DOING A GREAT
JOB PROTECTING THE BALL AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY HE IS THE GUY
THAT THE GUYS LISTEN TO.
THEY RESPECT HIM AND HE HAS OUR
TEAM GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
>> WITH THAT SAID THE MOVE THAT
HE PUT ON GETTING INTO THE END
ZONE, I'M IT WAS A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO AGAINST ARIZONA.
WERE YOU EXPECTING THAT?
>> NO.
WE STRUGGLED IN THE RED ZONE
THE WEEK BEFORE AND HE SAID GET
ME QUARTERBACK RUNS AND WE WERE
LAUGHING SAYING THAT LAMAR
JACKSON IS FROM LOUISVILLE BUT
NOT TEDDY.
THAT IS NOT YOU.
BUT HE MADE IT HAPPEN.
A WINNER AND FINDS A WAY TO GET
THINGS DONE.
THE BIGGEST THING ABOUT TEDDY
BRIDGE WATER IS THE WAY HIS
TEAMMATES REACTED.
THEY ARE ONE HUNDRED PERCENT IN
WITH THEM.
>> DID HE SAY SOMETHING AFTER
HE GOT IN THE END ZONE WITH
THAT BEAUTIFUL MANEUVER.
>> HE SAYS SOMETHING TO ME ALL
THE TIME.
HE IS FUN TO BE AROUND AND HE
CAN RUN THE FOOTBALL.
SPEAKING OF RUNNING THE
FOOTBALL WHAT IS CHRISTEN
MCCAFFREY'S STATUS.
>> WE HOPE TO HAVE HIM BACK
SOON.
HE IS GETTING PROGRESS TODAY TO
SEE HOW FAR HIS PROGRESS HAS
COME.
CHRISTEN IS A TEAM GUY AND
ELITE PLAYER AND WORKER THAT I
HAVE TOLD HIM YOU ARE NOT
COMING BACK UNTIL YOU ARE ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT AND THE
TRAINERS SIGN OFF.
YOU WILL FEEL GOOD.
HE IS PLANNING TO COME BACK SO
WE HOPE IT WILL BE SOON BUT WE
-- THEY ARE SMART IN TERMS OF
GETTING THE RIGHT TESTS.
>> MIKE DAVIS HAS BEEN DYNAMIC
IN THE ROLE OF, I GUESS, IF YOU
WILL, LEAD BACK.
WHEN MCCAFFREY RETURNS AND I
MUST ADMIT THERE IS A FANTASY
FOOTBALL ELEMENT IN THIS
INVOLVING THE PERSON ASKING THE
QUESTION RIGHT NOW, COACH.
IS MIKE DAVIS GOING TO HAVE
MORE OF A SIGNIFICANT ROLE THAN
ANY NUMBER TWO BACK BEHIND
MCCAFFREY HAS HAD IN PREVIOUS
YEARS?
>> YEAH.
I DEFINITELY THINK SO.
I THINK JOE IS CREATIVE AND HE
AND HIS STAFF DO A GREAT JOB OF
FINDING GUY'S STRENGTH
UTILIZING THEM SO EVEN BEFORE
CHRISTEN GOT HURT WE KNEW MIKE
DESERVED A CHANCE TO PLAY AND
IF HE COULD BRING SOMETHING TO
THE TABLE, I THINK USING BOTH
OF THEM AND DIFFERENT TIMES
THOSE ARE ALL THINGS THAT WOULD
HELP US AND I THINK MIKE HAS
SHOWN EVERYBODY THAT WERE GIVEN
A CHANCE HE CAN PLAY FOOTBALL
AT A HIGH LEVEL AND HE DID
YESTERDAY.
>> AGAIN, YOU ARE THE COACH AND
YOU HAVE GOTTEN THIS POSITION
BECAUSE OF YOUR ABILITY TO
COACH.
BUT I THINK THAT IS SMART OF
YOU.
I THINK IT IS WISE TO GIVE MIKE
DAVIS' TOUCHES.
I THINK HE IS A GUY TO GET IN
THE END ZONE FOR YOU, COACH.
>> IS HE ON YOUR TEAM?
>> YES, HE IS BY THE WAY.
YES, HE IS.
AND JUST SO YOU UNDERSTAND,
THIS IS NOT MY FIRST RODEO
DOING THIS WITH AN NFL HEAD
COACH.
WHEN SEAN PAYTON TURNED DOWN
ALVIN CAMARA'S CHANCES FROM THE
TWO NATIONAL LEAGUE I TAUGHT
HIM WHAT THE TERM VULTURE MET
IN FANTASY FOOTBALL.
HE DIDN'T KNOW.
>> THAT'S AWESOME.
>> JUST THROWING THAT OUT FOR
YOU TO CONSIDER THAT.
HEY, LOOK IT IS EMBARRASSMENT.
THINGS ARE GOING SO WELL FOR
YOU ON OFFENSE AS WELL.
ROBBIE ANDERSON HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY COMING ON STRONG
THE REST OF YOUR OFFENSE.
HAVE YOU REACHED YOUR STRIDE?
IS THIS WHAT WE ARE SEEING
RIGHT NOW IS THE HE YOU
BRINGING JOE BRADY IN FROM LSU
AND YOU COMING FROM BAYLOR, ARE
WE SEEING IS THIS DEVELOP RIGHT
NOW, COACH?
>> WE ARE CERTAINLY BETTER THAN
WE WERE WEEK ONE.
SO I HOPE WE WILL GET BETTER
AND BETTER.
YOU MENTIONED THAT WE HAVE
ROBBIE PLAYING GOOD FOOTBALL
AND TEDDY IS PLAYING GOOD
FOOTBALL AND MIKE DAVIS AND
TMENT J MOORE.
EVERY GAME IS A HUGE PLAY AND
CURTIS SAMUELS A DO IT ALL GUY.
WE HAVE GOOD PLAYERS AND
PLAYING WELL AND YOU KNOW JOE
DOES A GREAT JOB OF BEING
CREATIVE AND FINDING DIFFERENT
WAYS AND FUN TO BE A PART OF
AND I AM LEARNING A LOT AS WE
GO THROUGH THIS.
I BELIEVE THE PLAYERS WIN GAMES
AND THEY ARE MAKING THE PLAYS
IT TAKES TO WIN.
>> WHEN YOU SAY LEARNING, WHAT
IN THE FIRST FIVE GAMES OF
BEING NFL HEAD COACH IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU ARE LIKE
OKAY, I GET IT OR SOMETHING
THAT I NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN FROM WEEK
TWO, ETC., AND SO FORTH.
WHAT IS THAT FOR YOU SO FAR?
>> I THINK A COUPLE OF THINGS.
I THINK NUMBER ONE THESE GAMES
ARE GOING TO COME DOWN TO THE
END.
YOU CAN BE UP TWO SCORES AND
THE OTHER TEAM, THEY WILL COME
SURGING BACK.
NOT LIKE COLLEGE THAT HE MAY
WIN 48-7, THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
OFTEN.
TO ME IT IS ALL ABOUT GETTING
COMFORTABLE IN THE 4th QUARTER
AND FINDING PLAYERS THAT
LOVEMAKING PLAYS WHEN THE GAME
IS ON THE LINE.
AND I THINK IF YOU DO THAT,
THEN YOU WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
WIN EVERY GAME.
AND YOU KNOW WE ARE 3-2 AND WE
HAVE HAD A CHANCE IN EVERY GAME
TO WIN THE GAME OR LOSE THE
GAME.
THAT, TO ME IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST DIFFERENCES AND I THINK
THE OTHER DIFFERENCE IS REALLY
JUST ADJUSTING TO NOT MANY
PEOPLE IN THE STANDS AND
COMMUNICATION AND ALL OF THOSE
DIFFERENT THINGS.
IT IS SO DIFFERENT THAT I THINK
EVERYONE IS HAVING TO GET USED
TO AND HOPEFULLY IT IS NOT HERE
FOR LONG BUT SOMETHING WE HAVE
TO HANDLE RIGHT NOW.
>> COACH, YOU COME FROM THE BIG
12, I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY GAMES
COME DOWN TO THE LAST
POSSESSION THERE.
IT IS USUALLY 60 TO 59.
YOU KNOW, DID YOU CATCH TEXAS
AND OKLAHOMA OVER THE WEEKEND?
>> YES, I DID.
I WATCHED EVERY SECOND AND
GOING BACK AND FORTH.
I HAD TO GET READY FOR MY MEDIA
CALL AND I WAS WATCHING THE
GAME HURRYING IT UP SO I COULD
DO A GREAT MEDIA CALL.
>> I WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NFL GAME DAY MORNING ZOOM.
WE WERE ALL LIKE SCREAMING
INMENT MIDDLE OF IT EVERY TWO
SECONDS BUT ANOTHER TWO
OVERTIMES TO GO AFTER THE TWO
HOUR MEETING SO THAT IS JUST
THE WAY IT KIND OF GOES.
DO YOU MISS ANY OF THAT AT ALL?
>> YOU KNOW, I LOVE COLLEGE
FOOTBALL.
I LOVE WATCHING IT.
BUT AT BAYLOR LAST YEAR WE WON
11 GAMES AND MOST OF THEM CAME
DOWN TO THE LAST COUPLE OF
POSSESSIONS.
WE DIDN'T HAVE ONE OF THOSE 60
POINT OFFENSES.
WE WERE MORE COMMON THAT WAY.
WE PLAYED DEFENSE AND THAT.
I LIKE COLLEGE FOOTBALL.
IT IS FUN TO DO AND CERTAINLY
ENJOYING THE PROS AND BEING A
COLLEGE FAN ON SATURDAY.
>> I AM SURE YOU MUST HAVE
WATCHED THURSDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL
AS WELL.
TAKING A PEEK AT YOUR NEXT
OPPONENT IN THE CHICAGO BEARS
AND WHAT CHALLENGE DOES THAT
REPRESENT FOR YOU, SIR?
>> WELL, YOU START WITH THE
DEFENSIVE LINE AND THE DEFENSE.
THEY ARE FANTASTIC.
WE HAVE BEEN PLAYING KALIL MACK
SINCE HE WAS A PLAYER AT
BUFFALO.
HE IS A DOMINANT PLAYER.
THEY HAVE GREAT PLAYERS AND
NICK FOLES IS JUST A WINNER.
ANYTIME YOU PLAY AGAINST HIM
YOU KNOW IT WILL BE HARD TO --
EXCUSE ME.
SORRY.
IT IS GOING TO BE HARD TO
RATTLE HIM.
HE FINDS A WAY TO GET IT DONE.
FOR US WE ARE GOING TO BUILD UP
A GREAT PLAN AND KNOW THAT THE
GAME WILL PROBABLY COME DOWN TO
THE 4th QUARTER AND WE WILL
JUST HAVE TO TRUST THE GUYS TO
MAKE PLAYS.
>> LET ME JUST WRAP IT UP WITH
THIS.
NICK FOLES IS INSPIRING STORY
BUT YOU HAVE YOUR QUARTERBACK
THAT HAS AMAZING STORY TO TELL
AND I KNOW THAT I CAN HEAR IT
IN YOUR VOICE, YOU SAID IT NO
FEWER THAN TWO OR THREE TIMES
AGAINST BRIDGEWATER AND THE
GUYS WANT TO PLAY HARD FOR HIM.
GIVE ME A GOOD STORY ABOUT WHAT
YOU HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND.
IN A ZOOM MEETING OR OVER THE
SUMMER OR ANYTHING FROM
TRAINING CAMP OR ANYTHING
DURING A GAME OVER THE FIRST
FIVE WEEKS OF BEING EXPOSED TO
THIS GUY AS A PROFESSIONAL
FOOTBALL QUARTERBACK, COACH.
>> WELL, I WOULD SAY THAT MY
SON SHOWED UP THE FIRST DAY TO
BE LIKE EQUIPMENT ROOM BALL BOY
INTERN.
DOESN'T KNOW ANYBODY AND
DOESN'T HAVE ANY FRIENDS IN
CHARLOTTE BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC AND HE SHOWS UP THE
FIRST DAY AND I SEE HIM WAY UP
AHEAD OF THE HALLWAY AND IN THE
CAFETERIA AND I SEE TEDDY
WALKING BY HIM ON THE WAY TO A
MEETING AND WHAT'S UP, HE KNEW
HIS NAME ALREADY.
IT IS SIMPLE LITTLE THINGS LIKE
THAT.
YOU WATCH HIM WALK IN THE
CAFETERIA AND KNOWS EVERYBODY
BY NAME.
I THINK TEDDY REALIZES THAT ONE
OF HIS MISSIONS IN LIFE IS TO
BRING JOY TO OTHER PEOPLE TO
MAKE PEOPLE THE BEST VERSIONS
OF THEMSELVES.
HE DOES THAT JUST BY BEING A
GREAT DUDE TO EVERYBODY.
HE IS NOTHING OTHER THAN TEDDY
AND THAT'S A SPECIAL TRAIT.
>> HOW OLD IS YOUR SON?
>> HE IS 15.
>> SO HERE YOU GOT A TEENAGER,
MY GOSH IN A PANDEMIC DOING --
I'M ASSUMING WHEN HE IS
INVOLVED AT SCHOOL ONLINE, AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE AND HERE
IS THE QUARTERBACK OF DAD'S
TEAM SAYING HI TO THAT BY NAME
IN THE HALLWAY.
THAT HAS TO MEAN A TON, MATT.
>> YES.
THERE WAS A LOCAL GOLF CAMP AND
TENNIS CAMP AND MY WIFE TRIED
TO GET HIM TO GO AND HE
WOULDN'T GO AND SHE COULDN'T
UNDERSTAND IT.
HE COMES TO WORK AND HANGS OUT
WITH CHRISTEN MCCAFFREY.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO HANG OUT
WITH DAD BUT WITH TEDDY B. HE
IS HAVING THE TIME OF HIS LIFE.
THERE IS A GREAT GROUP OF GUYS
ON THIS TEAM.
I WANT HIM TO KNOW THAT.
>> COACH, THANKS FOR THE CALL
AND APPRECIATE IT AND LET'S
CHECK IN DOWN THE LINE
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE THREE
GAME WIN STREAK.
I WILL LOOK AT YOU WITH THAT
ADVISOR.
MIKE DAVIS ON THE FIELD.
JUST KNOW THAT HE NEEDS THE
FOOTBALL.
OKAY?
>> DON'T BE A VULTURE.
GOT IT.
>> HE SHOULD BE A VULTURE.
HE SHOULD BE IS WHAT I'M
SAYING.